they also say that red can make us feel
energized let's serve up some news
sunny side up never have i ever
ghosted someone yahoo life reports on a
new study that finds that ghosting
disappearing from a romantic interest is
actually on the decline
but cuffing cozying up with a partner
for the winter months is on the rise
some experts say it's the result of
self-reflection that took place during
this last year's extended
alone time but maybe it's not so
wholesome
and more about finding a cuff buddy
call me christine yahoo news reports
people are turning to sunrise light
alarm clocks to help get out of bed
easier
you set when you want the sun to rise
and then it slowly brightens to wake you
up
you literally wake up at 4am which i've
always done for work anyway but it never
gets any easier you get up at 4am and
then the minute your kids start to be
able to sleep till eight
they gotta get up at six for school it
is sadistic
so a local paper and you know we love
our locals in the
putnam examiner it says that
incorporating the color
pink into your living space can help
fight the winter blues apparently pink
puts this in a good mood and make kiss
all feel calm actually if you go to our
pinterest page
check out my personal board calm rooms
you'll see
where my head is at they also say that
red can make us feel
energized and that green
supposedly triggers optimism
and yellow our signature color here
leads to happiness and spontaneity
people reports that olivia wilde has
been seen holding hands
with harry styles turns out she's only
looking in one direction
they work together on a movie she was
directing called don't worry darling and
okay for starters uh this is the romance
i didn't know
that i needed to happen and i'm so into
it
how do you feel it's um you it's
undeniable they're both such incredibly
talented beautiful
inside and out alluring figures um
so i think i really understand why this
is
captivating everybody right now and it's
an antidote
to the realities that we're also going
through
so but also i just think about the baby
they have and like the jawline that baby
would have
and then also think about this i've done
the math so olivia wilde marries harry
styles and she hyphenates her name
olivia wilde styles i'm just saying
you're welcome and the new york times
they say they have just the plan for us
they say we should think
small think of fitness like we think of
food and start
exercise snacking that's what they call
it which i think is cruel because it
makes me want to cookie snacking
but what they mean is little bursts of
exercise when you can fit it in
so could you would you bear with me and
try something of course
i'm going to do a squat and see if i can
hold it as we do this story okay three
two
go and this is where we go up okay
science scientists say
uh even little bite size four second
bursts of activity
can have a huge impact on your health so
instead of reaching for a salty chip
you can just you know do a wall sit
what's a wall sit